pas
[Musique]
ce vendredi 17 mai s'est déroulée la
remise des prix du concours d'élevage
une action organisée par le département
à l'occasion de la foire de bras panon
daniel gonthier maire de la ville et
serge hoareau vice président du
département en charge de l'agriculture
ont rogné éleveurs leur récompense une
belle journée des prix qui sont à la
hauteur aussi bien sûr surtout que
filière aujourd'hui c'est un grand pas
en avant que fait le département chaque
année en revalorisant la femme
agricultrice l'homme agriculteurs dans
sa vie au quotidien
chaque année les meilleurs éleveurs
locaux sont récompensés dans huit
catégories sur la base de critères
techniques de production un concours qui
permet au département acteur majeur de
la politique agricole de valoriser le
travail accompli des professionnels ces
récompenses viennent encourager nos
éleveurs dans leur difficile métier
vous savez quand on est éleveur on doit
être sur son exploitation
sept jours sur sept il n'y a pas de
jours fériés ya pas de dimanche les
animaux attendent ces éleveurs pour leur
donner à manger pour pouvoir les
entretenir également et surtout montré
que le travail fait par l'éleveur est
essentiel parce que ce travail permet de
donner des produits de qualité avec une
montée en gamme de toute la production
de viande péi à la réunion et je suis
très heureux de pouvoir apporter
soutien ce soutien symbolique mais un
soutien important que peut donner le
départ tant aux différentes filières
viande
un prix qui représente une vraie
reconnaissance pour le travail accompli
par ces agriculteurs qui chaque jour
mettent du coeur à l'ouvragé
c'était comme un travail récompensé
c'est quand même la fois
tous les ans à part s'ils étaient connus
de venir récupérer se privera pas les
bleus
via d'autres éleveurs et et que les
numéros mais on sait tous les actes les
personnes qui m'accompagnent quoi je
suis content je n'attendais pas je suis
content c'est que c'est que de la fia
tic au froid treize chefs d'exploitation
ont été honorés ce jour-là et un bilan
très positif pour cette 42e édition de
la foire de bras panon
[Musique]